this was the view of Earth from space
that greeted guests on his last mission
four years ago he's about to embark on
his second trip to the International
Space Station or ISS it's a bit like
coming home I've spent half a year of my
life out there and have very nice
memories that I'll be happy to relive on
his new mission called horizons gas will
be the first German commander of the ISS
Chancellor Angela Merkel calls him the
German ambassador to space gas uses the
nickname Astro Alex on his last mission
he conducted over 100 scientific
experiments and a spacewalk which is one
of the greatest challenges for an
astronaut you know there's risk involved
certainly a bit more than taking a train
but we're not just flying for fun we're
doing research for the greater good of
humanity and for that I'm willing to
take a slightly higher risk one of the
experiments guests and his colleagues
will conduct involves a so-called flying
brain a robot with artificial
intelligence and a measure of humor
I'm r2d2 just kidding my name is Simon
and I will support you on this parabolic
flight the robot is being tested in zero
gravity as the first fully automatic
robot with artificial intelligence
Simon is unique the robot will support
alexander gaston his space mission by
fulfilling routine tasks such as
documenting experiments the first
subject of those experiments will be the
robot itself life is 10% what happens to
you and 90% how you react to it that
turns out to be a useful model for ghast
as he prepares for weightlessness in
space
well I think as an astronaut if you fly
to space you always have a lot of
project here and there and and you never
have the time to finish them so I'm
looking forward to maybe catching even
more photos / catching even more moments
in in weightlessness doing more science
and bringing it back to earth for the
benefit of us all Alexander guests will
have just turned 42 when he takes off so
he'll have plenty to celebrate in space
[Music]